welcome everyone to the June Meetup
thanks for being here and thanks for
being here virtually
very excited there's our second month in
a row where we did both in person and
virtual we're hoping to make a trend of
that we will have next month three
months in a row and that's a streak
so we're very excited about this and
we're going to hopefully have more and
more in person after that just it needs
to be the Confluence of speakers and
venues so by the way if you have a venue
or an office you want to host us let me
know be in touch we can definitely very
much use that first of all I want to
thank Microsoft for having us here today
they've hosted us a bunch in the past
hopefully again more in the future next
month we'll be here so big thank you to
Microsoft so what we always do the first
thing we do when we have the Meetup is
ask who's hiring
is anyone so if you're virtual and
you're hiring go to the Meetup slack and
go to the jobs postings Channel and post
your job there is anyone in the room
hiring all right so since you're in the
room you're going to come up and
announce it to everybody and Andrew Tim
I'm a manager of data science at 605. um
we're currently hiring like a mid-level
data scientist role we're an ad tech
company we also actually do some
political work if that's interesting to
anyone so very relevant to this talk we
work in the TV advertising space a lot
yeah if anyone in the room wants to talk
definitely hit me up after the talk
happy to chat about it
um yeah can post the listing in the
slack in a bit and talk to anyone who
wants to talk about it great awesome
and folks if you don't know the slack go
to nyhackard.org and at the top there's
a little bouncing like hashtag icon
that's where you can find it
I am looking for part-time and full-time
data scientists and Linux admins uh so
find me if you are looking for one of
those types of roles both part-time
full-time remote local I guess local is
still remote for me
um and let me know
all right next up the pizza those of you
who are virtual where did you get pizza
from let us know in the YouTube comments
and we'll see and we'll reply to you and
hopefully it's pizza if it's not pizza
you can let us know anyway
those in the room it came from Vito's
Pizza over on 9th Avenue so pull out
your phones go to bitly pizzapol bit dot
Lee slash Pizza poll lowercase upper
camel case go somewhere different it's
like a magazine and nothing to do with
pizza
but if you go to the lowercase one and
you can go rate the pizza now
essentially a one to five scale but it's
qualitative and that will go into our
pizza poll live data visualization
that's at nyhacker.org
so go in there vote on the pizza let us
know how you thought about it this data
is very crucial for the scientific
Endeavor that we have here
all right now that I'll give everyone a
moment to vote and rank on their Pizza
let us know how it is
um Pros cons we like to know everything
then we'll do just a few more
announcements uh coming up
July next month is the I think the Ninth
Annual New York R conference we're very
very excited about this we've been going
for a very long time there's our second
year back in person post pandemic or
whatever you call this time period in
our lives and we're very excited for
this
we'll be giving out two free tickets
after the Q a or before the Q a maybe
after the talk before the Q a I'm going
to give out one to someone physically in
the room and one to someone who's
attending virtually so we're gonna give
out two tickets to that we're very
excited for this it's a been a long time
coming the workshops are July 11th and
12th and you're going to see workshops
about machine learning with the Tidy
verse with Max tidy forecasting of
Rob Hindman how do you stand in Bayesian
statistics with Jonah gabri and causal
inference of Lucy D'Agostino McGowan and
Malcolm Barrett so that's always a
popular day going to those workshops and
then the conference itself is July 13th
and 14th you're going to see a bunch of
really great speakers like Bob rudis
he's a new one to this conference this
year Caitlin huden Max asamatumi
Rob heinman all these great speakers and
Katarina Constance danesco who's
actually here in attendance so we'll be
speaking so uh thank you to all of our
speakers and in the past we've done art
auctions like someone makes some sort of
art usually r related or data related
we're thinking about doing that again
this year so if anyone is an artist and
wants to donate a piece of artwork for
us to auction
we'll auction it off and all the money
is going to go to the r Foundation
and we're really happy excited to donate
that money every year if we have artists
so if you anyone's an artist and wants
to donate it could be like you know
actual paintings or it could be we had
someone make little like um coin purses
and we auction that off so anything
that's you know fun data science are
related well auction off and donate the
money so let us know
if you'd like to attend use code NY hack
R for 20 off
so you did 20 discount code just for
being a member of this Meetup and you
can go to rstats.ai nyr to buy your
tickets or learn more
it's worth it just for the donuts worth
it for the donuts you guys want to pass
attendee
were you there for the Ice Cream
Sandwich here
we did ice cream sandwiches one time we
got told they will melt because it's in
July's there will be Pizza there will be
egg and cheese sandwiches on bialys and
bagels lots of good food and there will
be plenty of beverages to enjoy
throughout the day
I mean all day from 8 AM to the end and
we are doing a special live recording of
the super data science podcast this is a
really popular podcast hosted by John
Crone we're really excited about it and
this year he's going to be interviewing
Chris Wiggins
Chris is one of the original members of
the Meetup coming coming to the Meetup
for over a decade he's spoken in the
Meetup he's spoken at the conference he
is the chief data scientist for the New
York Times and a professor at Columbia
so he will be interviewed by John Crone
on the super data science podcast live
at the conference that is really
exciting
have a few more conferences to tell you
about there's a D4 conference in Tampa
coming up in August 24th through 23rd to
25th it's a general purpose data science
conference about anything involving data
storytelling design it's a really fun
event I would tell you more but I'm
trying to hustle a little bit here
d4con.io and if you want to attend
you're going to be in that area or
virtual you can use code NY hack R for a
20 discount on that as well
and in one more conference sorry uh we
have the r in government conference at
Georgetown October 18th through 20th the
first days of Workshop the next two days
are the conference official details will
be announced soon we're getting the
speaker lineup finalized in the next few
weeks that is a conference about our and
Friends mostly focused on government
public service and that's Federal local
state and there's International
governments there's ngos it's a really
great time you might have to give a talk
there because it seems like in your
realm so it's a whole bunch of
interesting topics it's a specific theme
unlike the New York conference
all right lastly a few more things sorry
not lastly
um our next Meetup will be July 6th back
in this building probably this room all
right the speaker hasn't been announced
quite yet we're working on that
hopefully in the next few days while the
speaker lined up and all finalized but
July 6 in this room or on that screen
you're watching this on or your other
screen in your pocket whatever screen
you want to use
so July 6 Market calendar is really
excited about that we will be announcing
it shortly
are August speakers in the room but we
don't have a venue yet so as soon as we
get a venue we'll announce that yeah
there's our August speaker this is how
it works folks you sit in the front row
you become a speaker
all right if you have questions if
you're in the audience here at the end
we'll do questions you raise your hand
I'll come by for Mike if you are virtual
ask them either in the YouTube comments
section or on our slack at the monthly
Meetup chat Channel
you can find that mohacker.org and find
the slack there or go in the YouTube
comments your choice
and lastly for the people who are in the
room we will go to the bar afterwards
all right I don't think I forgot any of
our announcements I think that was
everything
so with that
this speaker by the way we found him
because he came to the Meetup a few
months ago and a nice East he told me
what he does I'm like you're gonna give
a talk at the Meetup so folks you want
to give a talk say hi
say hi to me say you have an interesting
topic
if you're virtual and we will have
virtual meetups again purely virtual so
you could do it from far away say hi if
you're going to be visiting New York say
hi and we get speakers this way it's a
great way to do things it's a really
great way to find new people so with
that please everyone welcome shubik
okay
um so thanks so much first of all that
Jared and Nicole for organizing this
talk and for wrangling together uh this
room it's not easy in the city uh thanks
obviously to Microsoft for for hosting
us uh fun fact is if you if you walk
outside and you look directly down you
can see the people who made this map so
thanks for thanks for that coincidence
um let's see thank you all for for
showing up uh to to hear hear hear about
this uh about this work and thanks to
everyone who uh tuned in uh virtually so
uh with that being said uh before we
head to our uh main course for the
evening let me tell you a little bit uh
about myself so that's me a year ago
um I am in the in the expanded R
Universe on what you call a social
scientist and I have the paperwork as of
a week ago to show for it so yeah thank
you thank you thank you I know this uh
this uh debate kind of comes up in the
data science community of like show I do
a PhD do you need a PhD to to be a data
scientist and kind of my contribution to
that debate is Loca phds a lot of this
but it's a lot of that too so the
distribution varies but just uh just
know that if you're if you're thinking
about that uh uh in your data science
Journey
um my academic research that I did
during my PhD
primarily was around political
communication so leveraging data science
tools including Texas data Bayesian
modeling and other things to really
study political media ecosystems in the
US as a side note uh this is a hill I'm
willing to die on I think political
science is the original data science the
word statistics literally means numbers
from the state so uh just just think
about that next time an arrogant
Economist or computer scientist tells
you what to do
um so yeah listen listen to us instead
um
so that's what I had been doing this is
what I'm doing now I'm a research
scientist at SurveyMonkey we have a
fantastic research insights team at
SurveyMonkey uh you know big shout out
and thanks to Laura ronsky and the other
great folks there who've contributed a
lot to the work that I'm going to show
you shortly uh so I work on what I like
to call full stack survey research which
involves everything from questionnaire
design to sampling uh waiting analysis
and everything else that happens after
after that a really exciting part of my
job is that we get to work with a lot of
these great organizations including as
you see here the Harvard Medical School
aapi data JD Power we have a number of
media Partnerships as well as well that
have been exciting
um
I kind of most relevant here to what I'm
about to talk about is I'm a creator of
the r package svmkr uh you can download
that now if you'd like maybe not right
this second but definitely you should do
it you should do it after after the talk
um I hope to convince you to do that
um and I have the Good Fortune of
co-leading our 2022 pre-election polling
partnership with NBC News and the good
folks over at UPenn who run the public
opinion uh program so you'll hear a lot
about that in just a second uh last
thing
um I'm actually formerly a microsofty I
don't know if that's like the fun tech
industry term for it I'm sure there's
like a better one
um but I did work at Microsoft that's my
connection to this hallowed building I
interned at MSR in 2021 I never stepped
foot uh in New York uh that year
unfortunately
um but I worked at the computational
social science group and we're still
continuing to work on using data science
to understand the role of TV news TV
media in election campaigns and if we
have time I'll tell you a little bit
about that work
okay so um enough about me uh let's move
on to the uh main course so
um this is how the Talk's gonna uh gonna
proceed
um I wanna give you an overview of what
election analytics uh really means
um and then I want to dive into uh
mainly this first application here which
is our pre-election uh polling efforts
at SurveyMonkey and again if we have
time which I suspect will be a little
bit short on I'll tell you a little bit
about the work we've been doing at
Microsoft on earned TV media and then
we'll have a kind of fun discussion of
what the feature of all this looks like
okay
so
overview of election analytics in brief
I will try
um
I want to start the section in a maybe
unusual way which is I want to put on my
my history my historian hat I think as
data scientists it's important for us to
take stock of where we are and in order
for us to do that it's really important
to take a you know kind of uh zoom zoom
out and look at how far we've come and
and and see how the tools that we're
working with have developed uh in their
long history and in the case of election
analytics there really is a long history
which really starts with the first
election well not really starts at the
first election the first election uh was
really devoid of election analytics this
was actually before the time of
political parties uh but the election
itself was a huge party right uh this
guy over here this is a painting of
colonial Virginia as you can see this
guy's having a lot of fun uh he's
refilling his uh his bottle on the way
to the polls uh this was a time when one
person of the population voted very
different time and so this was a time of
booze bribes you know fun theme songs
all the candidates had their fun little
kind of theme songs on the campaign
Trail uh some less Savory aspects of of
how elections were done a lot of the
political uh party bosses would
intimidate voters at the polls right so
uh not really resembling the election
analytics that we use today for the most
part but the Pomp and Circumstance of
Elections like that still very much is
something that I think is carried on to
uh the present day
um
so if we fast forward about a half
century 1824 is a super important year
it's uh really the year of the first
poll as we know it in the U.S and this
was a straw poll that was published uh
by the Harrisburg uh Pennsylvanian uh I
lived in Harrisburg for a summer they
don't make these kinds of papers anymore
sadly they don't do straw polls either I
don't know what's wrong with them but
this shrop hole was the first first poll
as we as we know it
um that was circulated public publicly
in the U.S
and so these straw polls were like the
the definition of like what we call
convenience samples right these were
observers you know journalists at these
papers going out into the street maybe
asking their readers like who are you
going to vote for in the upcoming
election there's a I'll tell you a fun
example of this there's one paper that
used to go out that send people out on
Fourth of July to all the local taverns
and they would have them count the
toasts that were being made to the
political candidates who were on the on
the ticket in the uh in the area so lots
of uh fun analytics being done but um
very bad in a lot of ways which we'll
talk about perhaps you already know
um and whether this was actually
informative for for voters uh it's it's
a little bit hard to tell uh right okay
so 1824 a big year
um the 1860 to the 1880s this is uh kind
of the beginning of what we call the
progressive area era in the U.S uh this
is around when the 14th amendment was
passed so voting rights
African-Americans kind of gained uh you
know voting rights during this period
um and really the important thing is
that there were a lot of these big voter
registration reforms as a result of the
progressive area era uh and the
progressive kind of era reformers and so
why does that matter there's a kind of
key uh part of this reform that's worth
noting is that you had to register under
a specific political party and that key
thing there is what allowed political
parties to actually start tracking and
in some cases targeting voters before
this was kind of an ad hoc thing these
reforms really brought about the first
voter files in my opinion
um obviously they were very crude in the
way we use voter files today are very
different but this was a big milestone
okay
so jumping forward again to 1924 this
was the year that the first field
experiment really outside of Psychology
was run
um this was a fairly sophisticated
experiment for the time this was a
two-stage block randomized voter
registration uh mailer experiment so
um this guy Harold Gosnell a very famous
social scientist the treatment group in
his experiment got these mailers these
very kind of funny old-timey postcards
that would encourage you to to register
for the upcoming election and he found
that the treatment group was actually 10
more likely to register for the upcoming
election kind of huge pivotal finding it
was published in the American Political
Science review and basically no one ran
an experiment again for like several
decades it was something that just
didn't take off for whatever reason so
if you're working on something and you
know your co-workers are giving you a
hard time and you're not getting the
recognition you deserve just like
remember remember this
um um
okay so jumping ahead
um 1936 is what I like to call the first
the first 2016 election
um so uh this was the year that the
Literary Digest which was
um actually actually a famous pollster
at the time uh in the last I think three
or four elections they were known for
super accurately predicting the outcome
of the each presidential election and
believe it or not they had these like
massive massive polls that they would
run on their on their readers like like
the one in 1936 had three million
responses right like that's that's
insane that's like big data as we as we
know it understand it today right and so
they ran their poll in 1936 and it was
like massively wrong it was like super
wrong it predicted that FDR was going to
lose terribly uh and in fact FDR like
totally swept that election
um one man one man saw it all coming and
his name was George Gallup and he did a
re-analysis of the poll he actually
re-ran the poll and he found that the
readers of the Literary Digest were like
very disproportionately affluent
affluent uh White readers who um were
were disproportionately
um uh Al Smith voters and so this was
kind of like the discovery of like
non-response bias and so George Gallup
went on to find his own polling firm and
he kind of Revolution revolutionized the
practice of what we call probability
polling right
um
okay so I'm gonna kind of speed things
up a little bit here uh 1952 is a big
year it's the it's what it's kind of a
milestone year for television the first
TV ad is run on in a major election
really in any election campaign that's
uh this at Eisenhower answers America
um uh uh in Academia this is a really
really big year this is like kind of
kind of the beginning of what we call
the behavioral revolution in the social
sciences and that's really born at
University of Michigan University of
Michigan starts this um really famous uh
uh panel survey panel that's called the
American national election studies panel
and it's the longest running panel on
U.S political attitudes that we that we
have and you have all these kind of new
tools that come to the fore I think in
this this era right you have the usage
of media Market data you know TV
viewership audience data uh the fields
of survey methodology and political
Behavior sort of come out of uh this era
and and Survey these large-scale survey
panels are really kind of starting to
become popular 1960 is a big year it's
the first TV debate
obviously we have a lot of wonderful
election analytics firms some of which
uh some of some of which folks in the
audience work at um these these firms uh
actually began in this in this time
period here so one kind of famous
example is the Samuel Maddox corporation
which is like probably the most like
mid-century name for a technology
company ever there's a great book that's
called if then which I'd recommend if
you want to read more about this but
these guys were basically doing the
things that we do today back in 1960
including predicting county level
election results simulating the
Electoral College these guys were all
doing that this isn't this is what they
were doing it on this was called the
people machine and so all of this stuff
has been going on for a very very long
time
um I'm gonna gonna fast forward uh to
2006 obviously a lot of stuff happens
between then telephone polling becomes
kind of a dominant form of polling or
you know kind of like birth of Jesus
moment happens in the 90s when R is
invented right
um uh 2006 I think is a special year
it's the rise of nudges and kind of the
Behavioral Science uh era one of the
most famous political science papers I
think ever published the Gerber and
Gerber and green 2008 which is basically
a replication of what Gosnell did in
1924 finding that um not just mailers
but mailers that tell you how your
neighbors vote can be effective in
getting out the vote in fact can be even
more effective than uh what what Gosnell
found with just kind of normal normal uh
voter registration mailers okay so 2006
Big Year 2008 is perhaps the biggest
year in recent decades it's sort of like
the dawn of the Big Data era the Obama
08 campaign kind of revolutionized and
modernized campaign analytics a lot of
the folks who worked on the campaign
these alumni went on to kind of found
and advise a lot of the analytics firms
that do great work today uh 538
obviously was founded uh this year and
eight silver kind of revolutionized uh
public election forecast Public's kind
of a I don't know iffy word there but
um so so 2008 is a big year and and I
will say that this is kind of like where
all of these like tools that people use
in the analytics World micro targeting
social media mobilization uh these like
huge voter files that are merged with
commercial data and all these other
sources is using machine learning to
score voters like all of this stuff I
think really comes to a four in 2008
um 2012 to 2016 a lot of stuff happens
here I like to think of these years as
the tech elections um so I'm gonna once
again genuflect to our host
there was this is kind of a historic
period because
um this is the kind of the first time
that phone poll responses dip below 10
like less than 10 percent of people for
telephone poles were answer like picking
up the phone and answering and so
Microsoft research which perhaps many of
you know this famous paper showed how to
take a really really unrepresentative
sample not not through telephone but
through uh kind of another very very
popular technology the Xbox and they
showed how to take users Gamers like
Xbox Gamers and actually turn their
responses to things like who are you
going to vote for how do you feel about
uh the job that Barack Obama doing and
turn into a representative poll using uh
multi-level regression and
post-stratification a a technique that
is obviously since then become very
venerable and well known in the data
science world
uh okay
um some other stuff happens right so
non-response bias is kind of like pinned
down as the culprit for uh skewing the
2016 polls I'll sort of talk about this
a little bit but I'm just going to kind
of skip ahead here to to present day so
what is what is going to be the theme of
2024 I think you know the answer or I
think you think you know the answer
which is write the rise of the Machines
right this is what kind of everyone is
saying is going to be like the theme of
2024 right so in a lot of ways they may
not be wrong right so
um kind of for the first time ever a
kind of major political ad is mostly or
as far as I know entirely generated
using uh generative AI
um Can it presumptive candidates
themselves are are sharing pictures of
themselves uh generated uh by
degenerative AI Technologies uh and and
so on and I'll sort of return to this
but there's kind of a question mark here
for how this Milestone is going to look
but I do think it's going to be a
milestone Stone a year okay so 10 big
milestones in election analytics a sort
of theme here I think is as the vote as
the uh as the voter population has
expanded in the U.S you've seen these
kind of technological changes accompany
that so A big one happened with voter
registration and kind of voter files
with uh the 14th Amendment and then you
have these other uh other similar kind
of AD events the kind of Rise of polling
in uh um in the early 1900s so that's
that's kind of a theme that I would like
to leave you with like you know like the
the vote the voting population expanding
and technology in some ways is sort of
meeting the needs and the demands of of
reaching those voters okay
so putting my historian hat aside
um so right so some recurring themes and
characters uh in the in this history
that I just laid out for you
um but uh let me reorganize it in a sort
of easier way so
um who's doing this work right so we
have researchers practitioners what are
they doing or they're doing all sorts of
things right opinion polling outcome
forecasting message testing optimizing
resources all these things are things
that we care about uh when we're doing
election analytics and we do this for a
host of reasons right not just working
on the campaign Trail and improving
decision making a lot of election
analytics is done now by increasingly by
media organizations in order to inform
news coverage right
um
and so you know all of you basically
make up the how probably on this slide
but there's all sorts of tools that
folks use in this kind of current
election analytics uh landscape kind of
your mileage may vary to each their own
but as you can see it's sort of like a
big diverse election analytics landscape
today
okay
um
uh to kind of set the stage a little bit
and to kind of
um uh kind of tell you like what all
these like big brains have come together
to actually teach us about uh elections
uh I think there's five big lessons so
the first one and uh it's no coincidence
that it's the first one is that uh the
incumbency advantage the advantage that
incumbent candidates have in an election
is extremely large and if you have to
bet on like one thing for any election
and you didn't know anything about the
election ahead of time like you you bet
on the incumbent like that still
explains like something like 70 of
election outcomes in the U.S
um the second thing is uh we kind of
like hear a lot about the media and the
media's role uh in politics and Society
right like the fourth the fourth estate
right um but it turns out the effects of
media are pretty minimal uh in politics
and certainly in elections that's sort
of this like uh consensus finding that
we've uh we've arrived upon in in
political science rather I think you
should think about the media as agenda
settings so there's this kind of famous
quote that media may not be successful
in telling you how to think uh but it's
stunningly successful in telling you
what to think about right like that's
like what agenda setting uh says
um
uh third so how people vote is extremely
nationalized it's like extremely kind of
tied to their National Party
affiliations uh and there's typically
quite low levels of split ticketing
where people vote for one uh party at
one level and vote for another party at
another level right
um so that being said party affiliation
is still
um by far I think the strongest
predictor of attitudes and behavior
across kind of election contexts
um
number four and this is kind of like a
big butt here which is that persuasion
like campaigns persuading
um people to vote one way or another it
still does work it's not like it doesn't
work uh entirely it usually it works on
the margins so um this is a really
famous experiment that was done a couple
years ago
um this was testing out what we call
Deep canvassing the idea being that
canvassers going door to door they're
not just telling you you know not just
asking you how you're going to vote and
giving you like a five minute feel about
what the their candidate or campaign has
to offer but really having like a long
empathetic conversation with the person
kind of meeting them halfway trying to
really understand uh people that you're
trying to persuade why they believe what
they do and trying to kind of persuade
them
um I would say in a more gentle gentle
way
um this this has been shown to be
effective again in certain contexts and
on the margins and certainly not for for
everyone but that being said persuasion
like like still does work sometimes
um last thing is
um and this is kind of a similar flavor
to number four is that um okay like
incumbency advantage is big but it turns
out in competitive elections like other
things still do matter like you can't
just be like a terrible candidate in a
competitive election and hope to win
like things like what we call candidate
quality uh still and can do matter and
I'll show you uh in indeed an example of
this
um uh shortly okay so
um you know history and political
science lecture part over you guys are
all data scientists you came here for
data science and R so let's let's let's
talk about that stuff
um so in particular I want to tell you
about as I said uh pre-election polling
um and in particular pre-election
polling that we did at SurveyMonkey uh
this past midterm election cycle
so we had this partnership with uh as I
said
um these good people at UPenn the
program on opinion research and with
them we we basically partner to deliver
weekly midterm pre-election polls to NBC
News and in fact if I remember correctly
we've had this partnership with uh NBC
news for a couple of Cycles before this
uh before before certainly before 2022 I
think even as far back as 2014.
um and so why we're we're doing this um
it's really a it's really like four
things
um one is this is just this is news
content right like polls are covered in
the news like it or not
um this is data for decision desk
analysts right like the folks who work
behind the scenes to call races on
Election night like this this
pre-election polling data is actually
really helpful
um we created a bunch of public
dashboards and banners for for you all
and for journalists and for other folks
in the in the kind of landscape to
consume and finally and this is
something that not only us not only
we're thinking about it but I think
folks in the broader kind of polling
space are thinking about which is how do
we move away from the kind of like man
on the street Alex uh exit polling that
you you hear about and you see uh on the
news and how do we how do we kind of
scale that up and how do we uh kind of
most importantly drive down the drive
down the costs of that and one
possibility is to move to an online only
exit poll and this is kind of an
opportunity to test that out
okay
so a few things we learned from our
polls uh the first thing kind of most
importantly is that hooray like our
polls were good this should Inspire
confidence in polling our polls weren't
horribly wrong we characterized most uh
not just Battlegrounds but most races
that we asked about uh correctly and so
what you're seeing here is the margin
between the Democratic and the
Republican candidate in the general
election and for for Senate races and
you can see in blue there that's the
actual results and then orange is what
our polls
um what are polls summarized as being
the Gap in the week before the election
and and this is with all the waiting
which I'll tell you about in a second
and you can see that for the most part
we actually I would say we we sort of
nailed it we sort of nailed it um
and the same same is true for
gubernatorial gubernatorial races excuse
me
um
and so yeah you can see I think there's
something like 30 races here and we we
were uh you know we were pretty pretty
um dead on for for most of them in fact
all of them
okay so
um yay we're great
um another kind of important thing right
like
the thing that you hear about in the
post-mortem of every election right like
what were the issues like what were the
issues that drove the election what is
this election about and from our data
from our perspective this ish this
election was yes about abortion abortion
was kind of this big issue that everyone
was saying was going to drive people to
the polls uh Democrats in particular to
the polls uh yes
um twenty percent of Democrats said that
abortion was like the issue in deciding
how they will vote but climate change
was actually also just as important uh
for Democrats and getting Democrats out
to the polls
um for Republicans like without a
question inflation was kind of the
driving issue in their turnout
okay
um
you might ask whether this was the year
that you know
this was kind of be like a record year
of like split ticketing and people and
moderates kind of developing
sophisticated policy preferences and a
year of that this was not so
um
so what I'm showing you here is a
crosstab between
um uh respondents house candidate choice
and their Senate candidate choice and
whatever race that they were eligible to
to vote in and you can see here that for
example 90 of Voters who voted for the
Democratic Senate candidate voted for
the Democratic house candidate and you
know basically the same for the
Republican candidate right like a mere
three to five percent of Voters have
kind of like mismatched
um choices in how they how they vote
um mismatch is maybe not quite the right
word but they don't
um they're not split ticketing right
they're not they're not pairing a
Democrat with a republican on their
ballot
um this is just not really a phenomenon
that happens in politics today is what
I'm trying to convey to you
um that being said that being said even
though split ticketing doesn't happen
that often or really at all
we do see small but meaningful split
ticketing in certain contexts in
particular Georgia if you all remember
was an instance of this particularly low
can you know low quality uh Republican
candidate running and you did in fact
see
um
you know again a small but like a
noticeably larger amount of split
ticketing uh happening in Georgia so
um seven uh percent of uh Camp voters
voters for the Republican um
gubernatorial candidate voted for Rafael
Warnock the Democratic Senate candidate
over the um the uh shall we say low
quality Republican candidate Herschel
Walker
um you know that's like two percent more
than at the national level but you know
this this can matter in these kinds of
competitive races right
um
again that being said
um this wasn't happening everywhere uh
split ticketing Trends in Pennsylvania
were actually kind of surprising uh you
would think that you know there was this
kind of conversation going on that like
you know Dr Oz was also this low you
know low quality candidate like he's
never really like run for for office
before like surely people even
Republicans will be defecting to vote
for John fetterman
um
um uh on their ticket and actually the
reverse happened as as we saw it from
our polls at least so actually fewer
mastriano voters voted for fetterman
than did Shapiro voters for Oz and so
why this happened we can kind of talk
about that uh you know there were other
things going on in that race
um you know John fetterman notably had a
had a stroke
um in the months prior to the race uh
and so I guess the takeaway here is that
yes candidate quality matters what
candidate quality means to different
voters differs right it very well could
differ there are other factors here too
there's a there's a significantly
different kind of media strategy on the
ground between these uh candidates so
the story is a little bit incomplete
based on our polls alone but split
ticketing kind of different across
context okay
um I want to now show you how we
actually do these uh polls
so this is what our polling workflow
looks like at a high level
um again so designing our questions we
do this basically every week every two
weeks with all of our stakeholders we
sample we we actually field our survey
and I'll talk about our special sauce
there
um and then again we use our our
beautiful friend R to do all of the work
uh thereafter
um
so in terms of the scale so these um
these were daily surveys that we fielded
between Biden's inauguration and
election day all together we asked about
200 questions 200 different questions
not all in one survey that would be
really annoying for anyone taking a
survey
um but in in total
we got about I mean close to 2 million
uh responses
um still not as many as the Literary
Digest God in 19 in the 1930s but close
um
this was looking at about you know 2 000
daily responses on average and about 29
000 responses weekly and again I'll I'll
sort of talk about this but actually
many of the steps that you see here we
were able to actually automate using our
our beautiful lovely r package
okay
we asked all sorts of questions we asked
questions about Biden and Trump we asked
questions about issues of which you saw
some some plots we asked questions about
the specific races
um and then we asked kind of these the
standard kind of block of questions
about about
um about the survey taker right so the
standard kind of demographic questions
that you see a couple of Innovations on
on what we asked we wanted to get a
better sense of whether there were like
professional survey takers out there
taking our surveys like this was
actually like a big issue in previous
Cycles so we asked like pretty detailed
questions about like how many surveys
are you taking how many surveys did you
take uh before this one today how many
surveys have you been taking this past
month
um I don't think I'll get into it too
much today but we I I like to say that
we we um
our sample which I'll talk about in a
second I think uniquely was able to
capture like less professional survey
taker survey beginners if you will
um and then we asked kind of this like
set of questions about their turnout
history this is like really important
for
um identifying who's going to be a
likely voter right
okay now for the kind of special sauce
so we fielded our survey on the
SurveyMonkey end page and so basically
imagine every time you took uh let's say
a Google form right uh you got an
invitation to take a political poll
that's basically what the sampling kind
of mechanism is for our poll which is to
say an invite on the end page of uh some
percentage of uh daily Survey Monkey
takers I think it was about 20 percent
uh to take uh that poll that you just
saw and so the traffic for Survey Monkey
surveys is like several million every
day so even 20 percent of that traffic
turns out to be a pretty large number
um
and so as uh statisticians and data
scientists and um political pundits who
will remain unnamed you might wonder
like who like like what's up with this
poll right like is this actually a good
poll does this is this any better than
like the Harrisburg pennsylvanians straw
polls right
um is this a scientific poll I won't
show you what the rest of the thread
said but right like the question is like
is this like a good uh good poll
um
thank you Chuck Todd for defending us
um okay so I wish Chuck Todd had this
study that we ran recently because I
think it uh does demonstrate what our
poll uh does well and so just a sidebar
here about like how to evaluate a poll
on its quality right so one way that you
can do this and the approach that we
took is take known or known or high
quality population benchmarks that exist
out there right the unemployment rate
the percentage of driver's license uh
holders in the U.S the number of SSI
recipients uh the marital rate the
divorce rate right these are all things
that government agencies have like super
high quality estimates of and compare
what our
um survey survey estimates to those
numbers and compare it to like a
comparable alternative right and so you
can see here that our
um our end page actually beats out
um kind of another uh potentially high
quality panel panel alternative to our
end page
um okay so in the interest of time I'm
kind of going to speed things up a
little bit so in terms of the processing
workflow we use our dear dear friend
tidyiverse I don't have to teach you all
anything about tidy verse
um we we have some kind of opinions
about how we handle things like item
non-response so for substantive
questions things that we want to
actually like report about we just kind
of list wise delete which is kind of
like a bad assumption in some cases but
this is sort of a standard practice in a
lot of polling for weighting variables
on the other hand we actually recode
these and we've tried different methods
and you know like this is fine basically
um okay how we weight our polls so I'm
going to kind of speed this up a little
bit but um so the target populations
that we want to wait to are like some
combinations of of these these here so
adults are likely voters either
nationally or in these Battleground
States and we want to have these
crosstabs either monthly
or you know weekly daily or even at a
rolling kind of window day by day for
the last 28 days right and so um the
most important thing and waiting right
is like what are you waiting to what is
the population that you're you're
targeting and so we rely on the American
Community survey
um and so the American Community survey
has a really high quality estimate of uh
age race gender
um uh cross tabs as well as education
and census Division and we we use those
marginal distributions we also use these
joint distributions that combine these
uh in addition and this is like a super
important thing we also use the 2020
past vote in every single state as a as
a as a target distribution
okay and so um we take these and we we
just use straightforward raking uh don't
attack me for not using MRP we had
reasons for this
um if you'll note earlier I said that we
had 200 questions fitting 200 questions
uh fitting a model for 200 questions
every uh every week I challenge you all
to to do that
um working on the campaign Trail uh uh
this this turned out to just be the more
practical option and it worked like
quite well
um okay I am going to mostly skip
through this we have a way of kind of
um predicting who are likely voters we
use this mixed effect mix effects model
excuse me
um you guys are all sort of like
I would guess experts in the kind of mix
effects uh stand kind of lexicon here so
um nothing really controversial that
we're doing
um but we validated our approach to kind
of predicting likely voters and it works
quite well
um okay so we created a bunch of things
from our polls every week which include
obviously the raw data making that
available to our partners they also
include a number of dashboards that we
uh Outsource to a tableau developer you
can you can actually go to our website
and look at these even now we made
banners and this is probably actually
the most important output that we made
like in the polling World Banners are
super important they're kind of like the
shareable format or currency of of
choice
um and so we built those using the xpss
and the open XLS package
um and week to week we were like kind of
constantly
um comparing our polls to other polls
that were out there at the state level
uh in addition to the 538 kind of state
level uh average uh and we did pretty
well we were pretty I mean we did pretty
well I will say uh with the with the
asterisks there this like practice of
comparing your polls to others is
commonly called like poll hurting I
guess aggressively sometimes called it's
like something you should not like
you know not like put like a lot of
stock in and not use to adjust how
you're doing polling
um but it is a good kind of reference or
Benchmark to to do right
um
and in addition to that we were trending
our questions every every week too
um and so
um
I'll kind of conclude here with a
demonstration of how this entire
workflow that I've shown you a lot of it
can be automated using uh this r package
that we're we're currently developing
and as I said it's uh it's public a lot
of the features are still in development
how much how much time you're good
you've got plenty okay 15 minutes you
want okay all right
um okay
so um
starting at the design stage as I
mentioned we write up this questionnaire
kind of week to week with our different
partners and that usually looks
something like this right like fire up a
Google doc or write up the questions
that you uh want to be asked
and what we have is this markup language
that's called qdoc
and really it's just this syntax to kind
of specify exactly what kind of question
you're asking right
if you're asking a single answer
question there's like a tag for single
answer if you're asking if you're um if
you want to denote uh you know delineate
individual choices you can do so there's
um there's a choices tag but there's
also a choice tag to delineate that if
you want to ask a matrix question
there's a there's a tag for that and so
on and so on right and they're kind of
increasing layers of complexity so you
can specify that this question for
example is a drop down or you can have
it you know you you don't you don't have
to specify that right so we developed
this syntax that actually allowed
um
that worked very very nicely with r
right so the way that our package works
is uh you you have a oauth token from
your uh developer account and you can
actually like boom like directly read in
that questionnaire uh into r
and you can directly upload that to
SurveyMonkey no need to manually program
your survey uh this is that exact survey
that I showed you
um for the questionnaire of and the
previous slide
um
and so there's a kind of manual step
here right of actually collecting your
responses uh we think it might be a bad
idea to automate this step like it's
actually probably really important to
have somebody uh make the exact
decisions the parameters uh the choices
for the parameters of what panel or what
source to to feel the the survey on so
this part is manual as of right now and
so once you're done collecting your
responses you can download your
responses well first of all you can see
you can in your account what other
surveys you have and identify the one
that you want to download your responses
um from which is what you're seeing
there
um
we have some pretty neat code that
parses these responses quite fast it can
be non-trivial to do that for really
large surveys and I think we've we are
doing a better job of uh parsing this
fast and you get a nice beautiful data
frame that comes out of that
um
the next step is waiting right and so we
actually in the package have a number of
different targets that you can choose
from so you're seeing here
this is showing you the different
distributions for the U.S gen pop Target
that we actually used in our surveys
right the exact ones that I mentioned
before from the ACs right you're seeing
the the distributions for you know age
by education uh you know by region right
and so on
and so the next thing in your workflow
is to is is to do do the waiting run the
waiting right so we have this nice
little canned uh weight to function that
you can run uh and super simple super
super simple
um it can then uh rake your weights to
that Target distribution and not only
that but it can actually uh
automatically discover the questions
that match the rejects criteria that we
have on the back end to map the
questions to the variables in the ACs so
that's what's going on there that green
text is hey that's the question that
maps that matches to age or education or
race in the ACs
okay there's a lot of other bells and
whistles in this weight 2 function here
that I'm not going to get into we're
also working on a Model underscore LV
function that is taking this a step
further and actually generating likely
voter probabilities for each respondent
in the survey
you can you know just do that and just
call it a day and run that you can have
the function actually cross validate
between a bunch of different models and
return to you the scores based on the
highest performing model our hope is
this for this to be a pretty canned
black black box is often set in like a
derivative way but our hope is for this
to be like a pretty easy function to run
if you're running the same kind of
likely voter model week to week
this is meant to kind of ease that
workflow right
um
you can do
um you know you can estimate your margin
of error in your surveys and
um
and lastly I'm going to talk about the
banners that you can make so assuming
that you clean your variables and you
know give them nice names
you can then go ahead and make your
banners pretty easily using the make
banners function you specify what
variables you want on the rows which
ones you want on the columns if you have
any weights you can specify what the
weights are going to look like and then
you can write your banners and you can
actually upload your banners too so I'm
going to show you actually what that
looks like
I think
Maybe
yes okay yeah so this is an example of a
banner that you can generate
um pretty much using this workflow so
it's nice and colored which a lot of
banners tend not to be
um
and you can see here that in this
workflow you can actually generate
like lots of banners for it for example
for individual states
um
you'll see here that it says LV these
are banners for likely voters if you
want to generate banners for other
populations you can do that but the
basically what our workflow looks like
using using as much r as we can right
okay
uh Go download svmkr
um in summary I just want to talk a
little bit about some challenges for
polling at SurveyMonkey
um and kind of thinking Beyond
um 2022 one is uh did we all get lucky
in 2022 uh and my answer is yes like yes
we did
um that's just the nature of off-cycle
midterm year polling the kind of
population of Voters that you're like
not reaching that's ten that tends to be
bigger in presidential election years
that's like a little smaller in
off-cycle years so that non-response
issue is is less of an issue
um and so you can see here so 538 this
nice uh little uh article demonstrating
exactly this that polls were
historically accurate accurate in the uh
the 2022 midterms
um
another question that we're left with
and we're working on and we're thinking
about is is what is the sampling frame
for all of those people who are saying
yes to taking a poll from SurveyMonkey
at the end of already taking uh
presumably long potentially even
annoying survey from Survey Monkey
already right like who are those people
it seems that those people are not
extremely skewed uh population wise we
have some other studies that suggest
that actually like our our end page
actually captures more Republicans than
Democrats that's kind of unusual It's
usually the other way around so it
doesn't seem like it's a super skewed
population but that's like kind of a
weird that's a weird thing to do right
asked to take another survey after after
already having taken a survey so we have
to have a better understanding of this
but of course there are some issues with
privacy here that we need to think
through
um
and kind of a third question here is how
can we take our end page and how can we
make it better and how can we make it
better using other surveys from other
modes or panels or um kind of meth like
you know Fielding methods this is a
chart from the Pew Research Center that
shows that
um uh basically the last couple years
I've seen an explosion in the number of
methods used to field surveys so it used
to be right and you know you don't even
have to go as far back as 2000 you could
probably go back to 2012 the year of the
the famous Xbox paper that most most
surveys that were done by national
pollsters were were Live phone surveys
random digit dialed survey that's what
rdd over there stands for and that is
like very much no longer the case uh
today in fact online opt-in surveys like
hours are kind of the dominant mode for
fielding surveys
this poses a unique set of issues we
need to better understand who's who's
going into what here who's going into
each of these different kinds of surveys
and I I think there's a lot of
opportunities to do better work here in
terms of blending surveys and in terms
of bringing in other kind of high
quality probability samples that are not
these online opt-in surveys
okay so um I definitely don't think we
have time to get into uh this uh other
work that I've done so let me skip ahead
to
the future
okay I'm Gonna Leave You with three uh
emerging Trends or what I think are
emerging Trends in election analytics
um
the first is the generative AI
Revolution and kind of a big question
mark here so as I as I said this is
already being used in fact this is
already being used to generate
fundraising emails that you may have
already seen
there is work showing that there is
potential for chat Bots to actually
simulate the kind of deep canvassing
that I was telling you about
um people have figured out ways to
actually embed uh these you know these
chat gbt like chat Bots into surveys so
that they can dynamically update what
you're seeing on the next page of your
survey uh and it tends to and there's
some early evidence suggesting that it
comes up with more persuasive messages
if messages are going to be delivered to
you in a survey then a human could
probably come up with xante so something
to keep an eye on
um
I think we're going to see the scope of
analytics like the kinds of issues and
groups and voters that we care about
with our analytics
expand for example I think aapi voters
are going to be sort of a big voter
block that are going to that's going to
be of kind of increasing interest
there's a lot of fundraising and money
being mobilized to kind of better
deliver analytics to understand aapi
voters they're kind of an interesting
um sort of interesting Trends emerging
in that in that voter block turnout is
up by 20 amongst Asian American voters
from um from 2020 this is kind of a a
demographic group that I think pollsters
and campaign professionals are and
should should care care more about
um the third thing is that I think we're
going to start seeing more and better
analytics at the local and state levels
I don't have exact numbers for this but
they're for certainly for certain state
and local races there's more money being
uh being raised and being pumped into
from outside sources and I think have
ever been
um this sort of like nationalization and
this kind of calcification of partisan
identity
um I is is is less so down ballot and I
think there's more opportunity there
um to shape issues and shape the vote in
a way that you really can't for the top
of the ticket choice that voters are
making
um and I think Republicans are paying
attention to this uh I'm not so sure
about Democrats so it seems to be an
asymmetric Trend at the moment but uh we
uh we will see and lastly there's just
more data about you like all of your
behaviors at the local level in fact
um this is for another day another talk
or maybe at beers afterwards but I'm
actually working on a separate database
that's called local view that actually
looks at um who participates in local
meetings using YouTube videos there's
all of these meetings are being posted
on YouTube if you spoke at a local
government meeting I I have you on my
laptop so keep that in mind uh that
being said uh that's all I got so let's
keep the conversation going obviously
say welcome questions but if you want to
get in touch here's how you can get in
touch with me
okay I will stop there
[Applause]
in the room questions start
all right I saw your hand first and I'll
come back to you
oh
with respect to using this these this
big data did you use anything other than
just plain old tidy verse to get faster
data analysis and when you talk about
waiting is that analogous to the
resampling we do in machine learning
applications to make sure that our our
training and test sets are balanced
yeah so repeat the question so the
question the two questions were uh first
um besides tidy verse like what else are
we leveraging either in the our
ecosystem or elsewhere to to do what we
do and so I'll answer that one first so
um yes tidy verse is super helpful
um in terms of refactoring code there
are limits to that besides you know
there are there are package level limits
to that at a certain level you have to
write efficient code that's like
language agnostic and we've certainly
had to do a lot of that particularly in
parsing parsing questions and literally
thinking about like Big O notation and
making sure that we're optimizing our
Loops
um so so actually most of the gains have
come not from like switching from base R
to Titus but actually like peeling back
tidy verse and thinking about how we're
writing our code and writing it more
efficiently
um the second question was about waiting
and so I think this analogy to um
resampling training or testing data to
for example generate more similar
distributions between your training and
testing set I think that's actually a
good analogy for what waiting is doing
so the testing set here you could think
of as the target population right the
population of likely voters or all U.S
adults and the training set you might
think of as your your survey or perhaps
your
um perhaps so so I should say that we're
we're actually when we generate our
likely voter scores we actually use a a
data set with a ground Truth where we
know who turned out and who didn't
um but yeah so that that being said you
could definitely think of that analogy
as working
um as operating how we wait
that's right
yeah if you had the the chat from Pure
research about the trends and how common
each of the polling methods are
um and right now photopolitan is
disappearing and often surveys of
becoming the most common uh what kind of
analytics would it be in terms of which
mythives uh the the most effective
for getting
yeah so so the question was in reference
to this chart here which is this kind of
explosion of of different polling
methods and whether there are tools out
there to help us think about
um
you know which to choose if I kind of
understood your question correctly or
how to kind of dynamically combine these
these different kinds of methods and I
think my answer is kind of inherent in
how I described your question back to
you I think that we are starting to
think about for example using these
tools and reinforcement learning to
think about how we might dynamically
allocate resources across say different
polling methods I think that the trick
here is that
um at Survey Monkey for example we
really only have access to one one
method that is online opt-in
you know polls we do have access to like
different kinds of online opt-in polls
like we do have access to panels so
there is some thinking about how we
could say dynamically over time as we're
Fielding a survey field responses field
respondents across these sources I think
the bottleneck there is that once you
start moving into these other types of
um polls Live phone for certainly but
any sort of probability based poll
they're just resource constraints
they're just like like literally
monetary constraints and and making that
happen so to the extent that you can
overcome that I think that we're going
to see a lot more of that in the future
hi I was wondering um
when you're tracking your poll versus
Seattle polls and 530v
um in the last election you tended to be
with the other polls and they were
reasonably accurate but what would you
do if
your whole heart could be different like
how would you
tell if like your your opposed you're
maybe your wedding methodology is
capturing something that's actually real
that the other polls aren't versus maybe
something the other holes are right
yeah so this is a quick question so the
question is
um it's about this this plot here on the
upper right which is this thing we did I
mentioned is comparing what our polls
were saying how our polls were
characterizing these various races
versus how let's say the 538
um average of all high quality polls
we're saying for that week and the
question is sort of like once we look at
this like what do we do if we're what do
we do if we're like within the herd so
to speak and what do we do when we're
outside of the herd like how do we
adjust our behavior and this is kind of
a complicated question right so
um if you're in the herd does that mean
that you're better like that's not
that's not quite the takeaway right
um
and so I I honestly don't know how to
answer that question because I mean it
didn't happen this this cycle right like
we were we were all sort of saying the
same thing for all these all these um
elections
um I will say though that if we did find
that our polls were outside of the herd
um I think it's not clear what we would
what we would do right like besides the
like the menu of like waiting options
that we have which I don't think it
makes sense to choose a different
waiting option to be within the herd I
think maybe if you were a very dishonest
poster you might choose to do that but
it's not totally clear what you would do
if you're outside of the herd um there
there was this experiment on the New
York Times where they asked a bunch of
experts to wait the same survey a bunch
of different ways and all of them came
up with different answers to the extent
that it characterized like the race that
they were trying to characterize like
differently so they came upon different
results so
um but it's not clear to me which
waiting method you pick to get a certain
kind of result like I I think that's not
super clear but maybe we'll cross that
bridge someday hopefully
thanks follow the question on waiting at
what level are you doing this is it
county level state level National
something else construct yeah
um repeat the question the question was
what level are we awaiting our polls
County levels state level something else
um we as you can see here we mostly did
nationally and at the state level we
experimented a little bit with um with
county level I believe at one point
um that's when you kind of have to you
know you got you gotta start drinking
the MRP Kool-Aid a little bit um and for
the for the 200 questions like that just
didn't seem uh practical for us but we
we did try that at one point it just for
um for the purposes of artwork that just
didn't make sense
um I there's a question on YouTube let
me ask that then I will come back to you
um
and because of my biked yeah I am so
this way you don't have to repeat this
one
um sorry if I lost this information
but I would like to know why Survey
Monkey would be interested in election
analytics and are they only interested
in U.S elections
so okay so I don't have to repeat the
question
um
I think our interest in election
analytics is demonstrating what our
first of all what our amazing great
software can do that it can be used for
things like polling attitudes about
elections in addition to a variety of
other uh use cases
and that's really what our research team
does right like we take our expertise
and serve in methodology social science
and by the way not just social science a
whole host of other things and we like
our job is to demonstrate how Survey
Monkey can be used to to do excellent
research right like at the end of the
day that's like kind of our kind of what
we what we do
um and election analytics is just one
small part of what we what we do um you
know all year round certainly all you
know presidential election cycle round
um I think we are interested in studying
elections and politics elsewhere outside
of the U.S in fact we have a very kind
of global you know audience of Survey
Monkey respondents
um and that's kind of unique in this
space so I think that is something that
we're excited about thinking about I
guess the right opportunity hasn't quite
come come around for that but we are
thinking about it
I'm curious about the uh the pole itself
do you do you think of it almost like a
living document that you're changing
to to
get your outcome a little closer do you
know what I mean like
is the reason that all the polls are
kind of around the same Zone because it
kind of just iterated to the point where
they're
they're correct no or is it is it more
of a
ambiguous a sort of a heavy flow on what
the questions even are that you're
asking
so do I have to okay so um the question
was
um how do we think about our polls do we
think about it as a living document do
we think about it as the static snapshot
like a One-Shot thing that we deliver at
the end you know right before election
day
um and how do we think about it because
as you pointed out the questions change
from from week to week so a couple of
things there so the questions change
week to week because the election's
changing week to week right like things
that are happening in in in in the
country the world the election the
elections that our respondents are
participating in uh you know things are
changing the Dobbs decision we we
couldn't have known that it was going to
happen that exact exact uh week that it
did
um various other events you know you
could talk about like mass shootings
these other events that we know can
influence political attitudes although I
think we show that they largely didn't
um we have to be kind of flexible and we
have to you know be be open to the
possibility of what's called all pulse
polling right like be responsive to
these events and and ask about them not
to say that that all goes into what like
you know the outputs that we produce uh
um week to week right these guys
um
but I think it's helpful for us
internally to understand
um what's going on I think the living
document metaphor is a good one I think
really like public opinion and surveys
like the goal is to like take you know a
thermometer reading of the electorate
right like that's what all the all the
great public opinion pollsters of of
yesteryear like the George Gallup types
like that's like how they Envision uh
public opinion polling so
um in that sense I think yes it's sort
of like this like living document of the
electorate or whatever other population
you're studying
page that you come from in terms of the
end page do you capture that do you know
where you the
the respondent has come from and is
there any like information from what
they've taken before that feeds in doing
feed into this
yeah so the question is
um let me actually go to the relevance
slide here because I think this is
instructive
so the question is do we know uh who's
coming from where when they see this
page and when they not only see this
page but they actually click on the take
the survey button do we know what survey
they're coming from so the answer is and
I should have really uh consulted legal
before asking uh before uh coming to
this talk is is I think yes
um the issue the issue is two-part one
is that we have this like huge data Lake
where all of that stuff is stored in a
difficult to access way but really the
bigger issue is an issue of privacy and
ownership so those responses are
technically owned by the clients who who
collected them on on whatever Survey
Monkey survey these guys came from so I
think there's an issue of ownership
there and I think there's also an issue
of privacy that these respondents are
actually not
um not consenting necessarily to have
their responses to their previous survey
be used by the research insights team so
um let me actually show you the header
that we
show
um
so so I believe there's some language
either in this header I'm trying to
speed read it now or actually in our
privacy policy itself that makes that
clear so I think there's some issues
there in terms of
connecting the dots
considered that like a source of
being able to like tie back
probability um
well it could be anchoring all right
because of whatever questions were in
the
the Survey Monkey survey before
do you hate puppies happen to be one of
the questions and that might condition
their answers on that right right so
this is a really good point that we
don't so be
the reason so we may want to know where
they're coming from for explicitly for
record linking we also may want to know
explicitly for uh measuring how biased
their responses might be in our survey
if they're primed or as as you mentioned
they might be anchoring their responses
to some stimuli they received in the
previous survey so I agree I think these
are things that we need to be finding
out but we just have to do it in a way
that's both efficient from our like
infrastructure perspective and also
respects their privacy so I think you
know one solution is that we just you
know we have a longer privacy policy
that's one solution
okay was your multi-level model lme4 or
was it Stan
or stand arm I should say
so
um
the question being was our multi-level
model lme4 or Stan let me actually show
you the answer
I hope I don't offend one half of the
room but I probably will
um
leaving you all in suspense here
uh which it was a simple average
yeah it was just a simple average
um no partial pooling
uh no it's not that one this one yeah so
we we use uh neither we use brms
um so uh we we actually started with
lme4 but then we used uh brms I like
brms uh
I also like Alameda and I also like stem
so I'll I'll leave it there cool
let me see this any other online one so
there's any other person once we're
going to do some we'll do the giveaways
and we'll come back to this
um
oh what is the Survey Monkey art package
going to be on cram
that is a good question so uh when is
the Survey Monkey package going to be on
Cran
um
at some point
at some point when it's not annoying to
submit it to cran I guess is the reason
so ever yeah maybe someday okay
no this here just does the package on
GitHub then if you don't want to deal
with crime yet or is it still yes it is
it is on GitHub let me show you the uh
literally glowing URL to the GitHub page
which is somewhere
I believe it is
here
great thank you nope we tried writing a
package first every month we called it
recess
monkey wow yep nice but it never we
never finished it so I'm glad you did
anyone else
um then right here that you mentioned
the um
the Xbox paper a number of the authors
are members of the Meetup and I've
either spoken at the Meetup or at the
conference or are going too soon I'm
major Gilman Mike maleki a bunch of them
are speaking there so folks come by
members of this community we're in that
paper that Landmark paper
all right last chance virtual and in
person all right if that is the case
let's see a big round of applause
all right everyone before we head out
remember July 6th that will be announced
shortly after that we have August the
speaker schedule but no venue so if you
have space let us know if you want to
speak let us know if you're not in your
city but we're going to have a virtual
month one time let us know if you want
to speak uh New York our conference next
month July 11th through 14th we're super
excited about that it's gonna be a
really fun time and and we have the our
gov conference and David Shore should be
most likely speaking someone you know
it's one of those Obama alumni you might
know that guy yeah you know that guy
yeah maybe you'll come down in the duel
we do we could do like dueling talks you
and him
I'll give you banjos and you can fight
each other yeah all right with that
thank you everyone for tuning in
virtually thank everyone for being here
see you all in July thank you for coming